[Music]
do you think men can be
no
not no i don't i don't think so i think
a lot of the feminists i know
the men the male feminists are
unknowingly doing it for a certain end
maybe they're using it as a way to get
close to certain women so i have some
very good friends who i've just felt
like we've had conversations where
you know he'll say something like yeah
you know these other guys at my top
university you know that
they do this and that and i you know i
i'm different because i can have like
um they're leftovers
[Laughter]
non-sexual relationships with women and
you know and then i asked them so
have you ever dated one of your female
friends i was like well he says well my
last two exes were
friends so it's like so if you date your
friends
then surely that makes your your beliefs
very convenient for you dating wise then
isn't it because so it's not
what's what's the word for when it's
like not um
no sexual intention
plutonic it's not plutonic if you date
your friends
um and so in my view i think they're
just unknowingly or subconsciously using
that ideology as a way to advance
themselves in a dating market is that
what you did because you said you were a
feminist for a little bit oh yeah
did you do it to get the girls oh um
hi
listen i had i had a time when i went
to speak such a nice guy
i had a time where like you know you
know when you're like you're in high
school you get into youtube when you're
watching all these extreme videos about
like tinfoil hats illuminati jay-z
rihanna
and i got into the feminist thing so i
you know i read some of their books one
of buddhist buddha's daughters when i
was traveling around thailand and now
women are generally seen as second-class
citizens in buddhism
they're seen as people who are incapable
of reaching certain levels of spiritual
attainment
purely based on the fact that they're
female and so there was a point where
i heavily associated or sympathize with
with the basic premise of feminism but i
never outright call myself a feminist
i think men have a natural inclination
to protect women too just like in you
guys as biology
so i think a lot of times when like
girls are advocating for a cause they'll
get their like beta boyfriends to go
with him
every every big fight has been typically
involved in a woman yeah starts off with
a woman always yeah 100 especially and
it's crazy these guys will literally
put their lives on the line for not even
the woman that's had their kids
it's like some random girl natural
selection though
i don't i mean i'm still struggling over
the idea that a man will become a
feminist
to
essentially
um
attract a woman or because if we're
saying that um the majority
of of of women don't like a man who
cries a man then gonna start crying to
impress like one woman it doesn't is
that what it's not that necessarily
it's
like if it was flipped and there was um
it was men men were i don't know what
the word would be um
and y'all were in your group talking
about men stuff personally i would
not become but i would want to
be knowledgeable in the sphere of the
male feminism so i can understand like
okay what are they talking about what
can i do to not like be extreme but i
can be like oh yeah i understand y'all
like oh just to like fit in so it's not
necessarily so you're not really
like oh yeah you wouldn't really be it's
like you're undercover you're like okay
i know what y'all like i can understand
it a little bit i can see it i can
finesse my way through it i won't be too
vulnerable but i'll just be enough to be
like oh my gosh he's so different that's
pretty much what it is well
my issue with when my friends got into
this some of my male friends were like
oh i'm a feminist now was like so were
you sexist before then
like were you were you just walking
around
why did you feel the need all of a
sudden to take on this mantle that you
conveniently have to tell everyone
around you about especially the women
like you aren't sexually women yeah
because
you don't know a feminist man that just
keeps it to himself
you know it's the the women will know at
some point he'll be going to like
female rugby games it's like you don't
even watch any sports why why are you
all of a sudden interested in female
rugby because your female friends are
and some of them are cute
so why are they the creepiest guys as
well like why are they the guys they're
always there
like they're the guys at the at the
party they're
you know getting getting a girl drunk
and
i'm gonna look after her take her home
stuff like that
what do you think octavia wow what'd
yeah i have another point to make but i
can make that in a bit but um
yeah i was because these guys were
asking me earlier like oh do you know
any like male feminist and i was like i
don't think i really talk to guys that
say things like that i tend to go for
guys that maybe if they have views
they're more low-key they wouldn't say i
identify with this ideology
but there's one guy and he
was he he says he's a feminist and i
think he's a communist result he's got
his strong ideologies
i didn't mention that
and basically he just said to me one day
that the best time he's had sex with a
woman is when she was like crying in the
middle of it and i was like
oh wow i said fetish crazy wow
it freaked me out so much i was like how
can this guy think that he's got good
morals but then do stuff like this i
think it's these people that identify
with these big ideologies that behind
closed doors were like one-on-one with
people they're not actually nice to
people
like they say these things to make
themselves seem good but then actually
as a person they don't have the best
values so that's my experience with that
guy anyway wow wow yeah
so are you saying there wasn't a second
date
you said you had some other thoughts
involving this guy as well to be honest
so i think
there's probably like a group of people
that call themselves feminists that are
very like
vocal and like are putting men down and
saying oh man need to be more emotional
and then like you you guys were saying
earlier like they'll even go for the
guys that are more masculine even though
they're putting them down with their
ideology behind closed doors they're
having sex with the guys that are more
like alpha etc but yeah this this guy
i feel like i'm quite a logical person
like i would want a guy to like uh open
up and be a bit emotional but if they're
too much then
i feel like it's just intelligence at
that point like if you're literally
pouring out emotions over someone that
like doesn't want you and you keep like
sending like toxic messages and all of
this like at this point it's not
feminism that causes you to do that like
surely you have some critical thinking
skills that mean that you wouldn't go
that far
like yeah this guy was
sending crazy toxic emails
like there was one time where he kept
emailing you after he was yeah he like
blocked he um he saw a video of me
dancing with another guy platonically
and then he blocked me and then emailed
me
saying after one date
uh it was a complicated situation with
him maybe a couple dates okay um
but yeah now he saw this and then he
blocked me and then um
sending toxic emails and stuff and then
yeah one time we were lying in bed and i
was like i'm just tired i want to go to
bed like just literally tired and he was
like what have i done wrong like what
can i do like all of this and i was like
i'm just tired because i i know it's
crazy
as women we want a guy that leads us and
so when we feel like like we're the ones
in control more in control of our
emotions than them it's like tiring it's
like you feel like their mother
yeah i was like why can't you just
literally tell me how you feel but like
surely going overboard is like obvious
that you're not supposed to do that as a
person yeah it's just lacking emotional
intelligence i'm sorry i'll actually add
something to that with the tell me how
you feel thing and it's more so i
learned from
girls that have been in the game right
that
a guy when she asks you or tell me how
you feel it's a trick
because the moment you tell her how you
feel
you've lost a point you think she'll use
it against you or something it's not
even that she may use it against you
with intention it will be like
unintentionally like you get into an
argument and
women and men are different when it
comes to arguments men have a line and
women
when they want to get into an argument
there's no line they won't cross
i'm not like that personally you know
i'm not like this
octavia is extremely extreme extremely
rational yeah she's one of those
one of the rare women that i feel like
says exactly what she wants and she
understands it where i speak to a lot of
feminists who tell me they want xyz and
i'm looking at like but your ex all your
ex is the exact opposite of everything
you just said um updated feminists who
telling me yeah be emotional i really
want to be there for men and that i've
told them like oh i don't get on with
this person then when we broke up she
was like you were dumping on me
emotionally
you know from experience
but the thing is i was a feminist so i
had to learn this stuff from practically
actually like engaging with people and
being like this stuff is not practical